m
[Musique]
des quotidiens
on n'a pas plus
il
[Musique]
on
mais
vous
[Musique]
non
aujourd'hui
des mutuelles qui sont pas considérées
comme victimes il ya toujours en france
des gens qui essayent d'avoir vu ces
démocraties
apparemment sa chaîne citoyen de la
terre
des guignols au pouvoir
ça fait deux ans
voilà ajouté
on va régler
et sa conférence
gardons et enfin tu commences à mutiler
des gens déjà et que ça normal ça des
blast accepteurs entre des gens qui
commencent à gals sacrément avec ceux
qui me connaissent pas il a perdu
figaro life 15h05 nous sommes en direct
la ici à la place wagram à paris pour
l'un des grands rassemblements de cette
rentrée en tout cas en ce qui concerne
les besoins sociaux et bien c'est la
rentrée les jv joint régie des jeunes
qui se sont rassemblées à l'appel
notamment de jérôme rodriguez pour bien
une série de rassemblements qui se sent
la coupe d'algérie
tout d'abord est bien ici à paris avec
trois rendez vous qui était organisé mon
dieu est bien ici place wagram avec au
départ de la place de la bourse en
direction de la porte de champerret un
trajet un itinéraire plus tôt de l'autre
côté bien on a tourné aussi vocaux
niveau des champs elysées mais alors là
ce qui peut autoriser la voiture de
police préfecture de police qui est bien
à renforcer ses dispositifs de sécurité
autour des champs elysées de certains
adjacent on n'est pas si loin des
champs-elysées ici à wagram pour cette
manifestation qui là bas s'est arrêtée
en direction de coire de champlain qui
n'est plus très loin
le rassemblement a commencé dès 10
heures ce matin pour la verdure beaucoup
d'interpellations
l'interpellation alors on en a plusieurs
dizaines on la sent des transports
actuels puisque les chiffres fournis par
la préfecture
c est donc là nous sommes à wagram
exactement je vais faire des couvertures
ensuite on ira alors déranger les jeunes
qui manifestent additionnant n'hésitez
pas ce que je regardais sur la page
principale du figaro sur youtube ou sur
reach a bien fait dans les commentaires
en réaction aux questions je les
prendrai avec le grand plaisir pour nous
de détails sur ce qui se passe ici à
paris
[Musique]
et
pratique
[Musique]
je le disais nous sommes en direct de
wagram alors que les biens la tête de
cortège
pourquoi se sont rejoints les deux
cortèges ce léger rodriguez et celui qui
partait de la place de la bourse tout à
l'heure à partir de midi eh bien on a
départagé il ya eu pas mal de tension
arn y en a actuellement avec bien des
personnes masquées
noir fort jeu qui se sont en train de se
rassembler à suivre l'action et je vais
vous faire vivre au plus près ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
ouais
non
[Musique]
m
à
celle de l'accord
ok je vends pas
[Musique]
tous
on
à temps
[Musique]
pour m
à l'arrivée
les tensions
ap
[Musique]
super c'est un petit peu ce qui à terme
se passer de la caméra donc je vais
actuelle à la réalisation
nous apprécions son sillage de m
[Musique]
vous
j'espère que la tête d'edf cette année
ce qui était particulier avec beaucoup
de personnel et alors que de ce côté là
je le donnais le monde
exact mais là qu'ils rejetaient alors
que du côté de l'avenue de wagram et
bien sûr gros du cortège
ce qu'empêche qui s'étend avec plusieurs
centaines de personnes vous pouvez voir
le tribunal de paris ce compte est élu
par contre pacific islands avec la m
du côté de ce partage
[Musique]
eh bien elle est d'avis que le
dispositif de sécurité
on n'a pas de chiffres des chiffres
assez précis sur celles fait parler
j'adorerais pour la police
[Musique]
oh
voilà c'est quelques questions je peux
aisément qu'une aide à la petite ondée
l'impact sur la pêche mais super du fig
1 m coupé puisqu'on a perdu le fil
ben c'est petr déclaré qu'elle alla très
particulier ceux plus tard et p2 ne sais
pas c'est tout et c'est apple qui on
veut pas dire qu'il y en ait
l'institut des risques pour soi samedi
c'était juste avant le pont seulement
nos deux semaines juste avant d'aller pu
couvrir sur twitter et j'ai pu courir
sur twitter pour le figaro select qui se
fait peut-être un pareil des débats
devant également et surtout par
l'ambiance est celle ci en pleine
période de pandémie et justin la période
historique de notre pays c'est du
compliment
en fait je veux aussi jeté des questions
là une question assez et je préférais
faire ma tristesse et on a beau dire ce
serait plutôt de verser ces
manifestations
satisfait si je serai tête à côté
alors 2 est en tout cas c'était un petit
peu je suis dit là en fait que tout vous
expliquer la baisse est asymétrique si
vous regardez derrière vous savez les
personnes annuelle qui se tenait ce qui
peut vous black box internet qui sont
contre comme érudit les coutures ce
genre de bless de s'équiper avec ce look
est bien en plein milieu en plein coeur
de la tête de cortège on l'abri des
indiscrets
c'est malheureusement quelque chose que
tu le but est un but pour les suites du
mouvement
à
j'ai en tout cas avec respect mais si
les travaux sur la plage principe est
défigurée n'hésitez pas à aller aussi à
poser toutes vos questions
m
conte
non m
[Musique]
perdu 20
à
là
bonjour à vous et merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur la page
principale du cigare ou sur twitter et
sur youtube en pleine tête de cortège
ici pour cette rentrée des gilet jaune
une rentrée qui est donc assez
importante et conséquente en ce qui
concerne le nombre de manifestants mais
qui n'est évidemment ne rejoint pas les
premiers jours et les grands jours entre
guillemets des gilet jaune alors avec
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes dans toute la france
ici est bien dans une somme plutôt à des
milliers de personnes ça ça répondra à
vos questions
bonjour à vous planète hoover vous nous
demandez si la manifestation est complet
avec des avec une manifestation sans
masque parce qu'on voit beaucoup de
manifestations parce qu'alors moi même
je les retirer mais juste parce que
j'aime j'ai ce masque là que je vais
remettre dans quelques secondes c'était
juste l'occasion de pouvoir vous parler
mais en effet il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ne peuvent pas leur masque mais ça c'est
c'est pas du tout signe de on va dire de
militantisme est en tout cas de raisons
pour être venu ici se mobiliser il ya
plusieurs mobilisations en effet avec
des appels à manifester sur les champs
elysées des manifestations déclarées
avec ce cortège qui a commencé place de
la bourse et qui va être destination
porte de champerret et ça c'est le
cortège qui se trouve juste derrière moi
mais en tout cas il n'y a pas de
manifestation particulièrement lié aux
masques qui a été déclarée ici à paris
aujourd'hui je crois savoir et je vais
l'entendre petite oreillette qu'on avait
d'autres questions
alors bonjour à vous professeur genki
sur youtube games qui nous demandent si
le nombre de manifestants tout
simplement
alors pour le moment on n'a pas
d'estimation encore en tout cas pas moi
je n'ai pas sur le terrain je peux vous
dire que bien il ya quand même plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes sont
nguyen centaines de personnes qui se
trouve juste derrière moi on doit être
aux alentours
enfin en tout cas au moins 2000
personnes après il faudra attendre les
gros estimations pour vous donner de
vrais chiffres en tout cas ce cortège
principal de vous dire qu'il est assez
pacifique qui a pas eu de problème à
signaler de ce côté là moi j'ai fait les
deux j'ai commencé avec ce cortège que
j'ai rejoint assez rapidement de l'autre
côté je me suis rendu à wagram où il ya
eu la détention plus importante avec
notamment un véhicule incendié
au total je vous rappelle il ya eu près
d'une centaine d'interpellations
mais en tout cas pas d'estimation encore
pour vraiment je pense qu'on les aura
d'ici la fin de journée n'est pas à vous
rendre sur le figaro pour avoir
absolument bien toutes les estimations
tant du côté des manifestants que du
côté de la préfecture de police
[Musique]
alors on a également une question de la
crosse lockwood qui nous demandent aussi
le manque d'information sur le
dispositif de sécurité est lié à la fois
l'actualité des dernières semaines
eh bien je dois vous dire que moi même
je suis assez surpris de cela on a pas
de raisons pour lesquelles il n'y a pas
eu tant d'infos que ça c'est la première
fois en tout cas que moi je cours une
manifestation qui soit en tout cas
particulièrement encadrée qui soit très
attendu de la part de la préfecture de
police et qu'on n'ait pas de chiffres
d'habitude on
le nombre de personnes qui sont
impliquées par exemple pour la finale du
match psg bayern à la ligue des
champions bien là encore on avait des
informations
je ne peux pas trop l'interpréter alors
est-ce que c'est dû aux passements de
vos placements de relais aux passants de
flambeau christophe castaner et gérald
darmanin est-ce que c'est dû à une
nouvelle politique de maintien de
l'ordre
on peut pas trop l'interpréter
malheureusement mais sachez en tout cas
que bien les forces de l'ordre sont
quand même massivement présentes et sont
tout autour je vais essayer de vous
montrer les dispositifs rien qu'ici sur
cet aspect ray sur cette place wagram
sur cette place du brésil pardon mais en
plein milieu de l'avenue wagram
voilà vous pouvez le voir ici les forces
de gendarmerie
alors que derrière il semble que les
street medic soit en train d'enlever
quelqu'un pour essayer d'aider mais vous
voyez donc 7 7 place du brésil qui est
particulièrement encadrée d'un côté par
les forces
gendarmerie de l'autre par les crs qui
se trouvent et bien en tête du cortège
principal chez lui et bien mis en cause
juste avant cette place du brésil
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
du tout bon
après
m
enseigne du valais
militaire
ce que des militants savent sur le kop
des armées du roi
[Applaudissements]
là
voilà vous le voyez nous sommes toujours
ici au niveau est bien de l'avenue de
wagram alors que d'efforts de crs et les
forces de police se rendent ici en tête
de cortège je vais essayer de me
rencontrent un petit peu l'ambiance
on essaiera de faire des interviews tout
à l'heure c'est beaucoup plus simple de
faire des interviews en marche que
pendant que le sommes à l'arrêt comme
cela donc j'essaie de vous offrir des
interviews quant à l'ambiance de gestes
à un peu plus détendu et sera surtout en
mouvement ce sera beaucoup plus simple
et donc je vois votre votre question
professeur genki sûr sur youtube je
crois nous demander le rapport des
manifestants avec avec avec les reporter
et journaliste dont je serais parti
alors bien évidemment il n'y a aucune
consigne et quand bien même il y en
aurait les respecteraient pas vous nous
demandez est ce qu'il ya eu des
consignes pour la part de manifestants
envers nous on peut filmer ou pas alors
non bien évidemment il n'y en a pas et
s'il y en avait avant les respecteraient
pas la seule chose qu'on peut respecter
ses droits à l'image
selon la volonté des personnes mais a en
tout cas sur sur les sur les différentes
les différentes actions qui peut y avoir
ici je dois dire tout d'abord et bien
que le rapport avec les journalistes est
beaucoup plus apaisé qu'il ya encore un
an et demi au tout début du mouvement ou
l'aï obligé plus connaître moi même qui
ai fait un très très très grand nombre
d'actes de jd je bien nouveau pour
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes avec
certains manifestants même si j'ai aussi
plus avoir beaucoup de belles scènes
avec des manifestants qui cherchaient à
comprendre notre place notre rôle et
voilà activer le débat au sein du du
débat citoyen et ça c'était très
intéressant donc voilà je ne critique
pas du tout les manifestants au
contraire j'en ai plus rencontré de très
intéressant et de très très intelligent
donc ça c'est pas du tout un problème
alors que derrière moi vous voyez bien
un nouveau tir de lacrymo qui s'est fait
et donc non il n'y a pas
ça c'est une grenade de désencerclement
messieurs ça fait beaucoup de bruit et
ça peut être dangereux si on est un peu
trop près tant pour les oreilles que
pour le corps si on a le malheur de se
retrouver un peu trop près voilà pour
peu pour cela en tout cas je dois vous
dire que ici bien l'ambiance est assez
assez détendu en ce qui nous concerne
nous et nous et les manifestants et
qu'il n'y a pas du tout de problème
là-dessus
[Musique]
alors je me dis que je n'ai pas de
masque je le remets justement semin
c'était juste pour pouvoir vous parler
de façon intelligente
mais nadal
thomas
[Musique]
côté maternel
en trente mois
non
[Musique]
m
à côté
[Musique]
[ __ ]
je
trop fatigué
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
ici la police avec un casque bleu alors
que
eh bien vous étiez de l'écrivain a peut
être fait vous avez plus rien tout à
l'heure le principal défi d'aller sur
youtube
monsieur je ne te laisses était question
de votre père jacky répétées qui je peux
pas d'incitatif n hésita touché mes
cheveux ont confirmé que je m'habille
les blancs
de l'interdire usé de certaines monnaies
et paysages de tremplin certes j'ai pas
pu identifier qu'ils étaient libres et
lèvres directement laissez donc je peux
confirmer le jugement
je crois qu'il est que situation sur la
puissance de bray dunes ont pu révéler
difficile l'identification exacte des
prêts nets qui sont utilisés ici parce
que la scène est assez opaque
j'ai une maîtrise qui se passe en direct
à la corvette porte et je sais de
diriger les produits axés études et chez
l'écrivain s'est projeté que le prêt
sera peut-être dès les jeux palais
m
la belge en vue d'actions je vous
confirme mais ça va dire que c'est la
pêche pas super efficace sur facebook
[Musique]
non
il
[Musique]
le coup beaucoup beaucoup de déception
c'est un monsieur cps du brésil qui pèse
l'avenue de wagram beaucoup de débit je
vais vous dire que je suis pas besoin
d'ouvrir les yeux la grèce s'est un peu
compliqué mais si elle venait avec vous
connais quelqu'un est là qu elle al air
d
les questions
mais rien
posé sur twitter même si jean et éviter
que les coeurs des problèmes mais pour
d'autres il n'y a pas de style attrayant
que ce soit cassée je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il est bel et bien deux portes
et je la partage ici qui est constitué
mais beaucoup de personnes habillées on
est là et si ça peut identifier
d'ailleurs vous pouvez le voir le témoin
il ya peu de chedjou qui sa porte et
perpètrent de l'autre côté à apporter à
ces places et plus adaptés à ces massifs
qui devrait constituer un bref martine
gilles et joissins pacifique a participé
des fermentations apple a pu observer
ici
si je le fais je doute de faire des
interviews qu'il suffit que les métiers
projet qui m'attire c'est le b vous prêt
réussi de faire mais la tête jusque
quand je puisse faire partir et que tu
as you say me lisent
je sais
bien
et alors
[Musique]
quand tu n as pas
seniors
non
[Musique]
l'êta fondée
à vue par an
[Musique]
c'est un comble
n'est pas
[Musique]
la drogue
pour moi
merci d'être surpris mais sur youtube
merci on applaudit en tout cas détruit
jeudi dans les jets et donc il ya cette
question sur youtube
côté j'ai bloqué bien le porter je
répète que sa planète jeunes était l'un
des crs des radios budget est libéré des
besoins et bien le gérer ses déchets les
têtes de cheptel est allé prendre
j'espère rythme et de manifestations
traditionnelles nous poser toutes vos
questions
il
alors je te tue un switch même demandé
si on pourrait l'imaginer je manifeste
aujourd'hui à la fessée la caennaise
ce rassemblement j'ai fait la paix de
généraux début je savais c'est peut-être
se diriger vers l'accusé tout et les
algues et les fenêtres guinée vous
pouvez trouver des critères jeu peut
diffuser ces images chez twitter a vidé
le temps des visites et prévisions cet
appel était faite l'assemblée conergy
site
dans cette période post crise sanitaire
qui est toujours élevé et surtout après
la pesée ce tir et des manifestations
avaient habitués pendant l'été il ya la
télé il ya quand même deux des vingt dix
échappés peut-être mieux le terrain je
préfère rester chez eux ce qui concerne
notre ami bien 18 mois ci aux états unis
et donc
d'abord la puissance
entre-temps été repéré mais cette
faiblesse est l ai dit combien c'était
d'aider à feu et étanches et affecter
les jeunes le prochain rdv à tu vas
tomber la veste à celle versée la
semaine prochaine le 17
avec cet appel à la grève ok j'espère
qu'on pourra le faire suivre la cigale
est également monté si vous ne découvrez
ces sessions youtube s'est achevé le
figaro switch ces chèques américain des
chaussures ici en direct auprès de l'
effet le matériel c'est un peu plus
calme et un peu plus constructif et
romain
rassurés les dispersions pèserait pas un
problème qui suit est sur youtube je
peux d'informer suis ce que je sais
c'est qu'il est très manifestations
devaient être dispersés à 18h20 et si tu
es que je peux imaginer que le chemin
est établi chaque pratique ces
manifestations et bien c'est un ps de la
bfbp
je sais c'est particulier on n'a pas
l'habitude de commenter je suis bon
jusqu'au bout
oui oui elle est bien trop de chemin
mais on a des décès pour observer ça
mais c'est un petit peu et je n'étais
déjà la libye gagnent aussi un petit peu
cette actualité
je l'aï vilain devait se jouer dans les
manifestations à l'appel de jeunes et
hobbies et d'humoristes nommé risque
s'est défait bien donner la main à
verser 28
il a annoncé qu'il est réputé reste car
elle se désolidariser du buzz mais pas
des jeunes
[Musique]
de cet appel j'allais à bégard dse de ce
label se désolidariser du message tiens
je me dis que c'est les coupent pas le
28 des policiers et des bases où j'avais
révision n'a pas soutenu cette opération
jamais à l'idée de se retrouver ce matin
devant le bcl étrangers aiment bien nous
pousser vers les diffuser dans quelques
minutes plus tard il advenir
m les spécialistes et surtout on était
violence et chauvigny tpe et donc et
bien
si la facture d'internet et du son sur
très chaude en bande à bébel
que ferais tu veux changer un petit et
il était bon et bien on n'a pas du tout
réussi ces nouvelles chaudières tout cas
je n'ai rien à perdre aujourd'hui je
vais vous laisser regarder ces images du
jeu vous demandez jeu et primaire
adeptes de la cci neige à la réalisation
ok je vous laisse regarder à ceux prévus
cet été
[Applaudissements]
alors
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà vous l'avez vu donc bien cette
scène que je pense sur ma vie on n'avait
pas prévu ce matin la place de la bourse
on arrive ici niveau de paire eur la
reine métro et on va continuer d'avancer
je l'espère mais le servent encore de
nouveaux arrêtés
voyez beaucoup d'arrière depuis tout à
l'heure en tout cas
[Musique]
jérôme rodriguez avait les bien réussi à
son échelle quand vous voir avec
beaucoup de personnes qui sont venues en
comparaison à certains moments des
gilets jaunes qui étaient un peu
délaissé ces derniers temps
[Musique]
à partir d'autres manifs et d'autres
habitations
[Musique]
du tout
mais voilà vous le voyez une ambiance
particulièrement tendue ici avec
plusieurs rixes qui datent de temps à
autre
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
[Musique]
ans
je vous propose de regarder d'autres
images les images de géants mortgage la
tête de l'une des têtes des plus grands
qui tout à l'heure était à bien en
direct je vous laisse écouter ces images
grâce à vous j'ai le tunnel à la
réalisation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les gens ont pas perdu comme
vide
ils ont peur des conséquences du coc
vite on n'a plus de bâton parce que t'as
pas de masque prendre une amende parce
que t'as pas de masque c'est ça la
réelle peur maintenant ceux qui ont le
plus peur ces lieux gouvernement c'est
moche finalement quand on voit l'arrêté
qui l'a mis en place je croyais qu'on
était morts les îles et donc sont morts
c'est halloween aujourd'hui dans les
bacs mais trop de pognon dans les bonnes
poches le virus aujourd'hui c'est la po
jouit le ventre vide
le fait de vivre ça c'est le virus pour
les français souffrent demandez leur
avec
là maintenant
pour ça
en quoi
voilà vous le voyez un petit peu de
course à pied alors que cette personne
vient de jeter un oeil sur les phases de
l'envol
un petit peu de course à pied car les
manifestants ont tenté de déborder et
forces de l'ordre
c'est un peu le jeu du chat et la souris
je vous reprendre dans quelques secondes
sur ces images de la spa tant que jeune
équipe car là c'est sûr ça va gaz et
c'est pareil
m
et
non
[Musique]
voilà
dylan
m
sarah
oui
[Musique]
moi
jean
voilà
alors quoi
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à vous d'être avec nous sur la
page principale du figaro
c'est une nouveauté j'ai l'habitude sur
facebook sur youtube mais également sur
tweets poursuivre cette mobilisation la
mobilisation des gilet jaune en ce 12
septembre
c'était l'un des gros appel de la
rentrée en terme de mouvements sociaux
celui de jérôme rodriguez jean rodriguez
le une des têtes léger des jeunes qui a
appelé à rassembler les colères jeu
slicks donc on est plus sur un format
d'actes même si on est un samedi comme
c'est l'habitude des actes qu'on a
connus pour les gilet jaune mais on est
bel et bien sur un format traditionnel
de manifestation du mouvement des gilets
jaunes avec donc bien quelques centaines
de manifestants qui se sont rassemblés
ici aujourd'hui
ou continuer d'avancer en direction de
la porte de champerret nous étions à
wagram on a été bloqué pendant un petit
moment avec pas mal de tension désormais
on peut continuer notre chemin
direction de la porte de champerret
alors qu'un autre mouvement lui a eu
lieu il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une explosion de cotillons mouvement
sauvages notamment en place des thermes
qui a lieu tout à l'heure alors que là
nous sommes de nouveau arrêté alors
merci à vous en tout cas d'être avec
nous ça ça vous pouvez répondre à votre
question qui a quelque chose sur youtube
qui nous demandait pourquoi il y avait
cette manifestation aujourd'hui on a
également cette question de vincent
l'eau sur la page principale du figaro
pour salut merci d'être avec nous
s'il y a
personne qui masque particulièrement non
il n'y a pas de message à méré ce que je
peux vous dire c'est quand même que la
majorité des gens ont leur masque sur la
bouche
d'habitude les gens ont des masques dans
ce genre d'ambiance puisqu'il ya des
lacrymo là pour le coup ils ont une
bonne raison de le porter en raison des
crises sanitaires bien évidemment voilà
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à poser toutes
vos questions à réagir dans le tchat
on essaiera de partir à la rencontre si
si le climat le permet des manifestants
et de leur demander un petit peu
pourquoi il serait aujourd'hui
du coup
[Musique]
merci d'être d'être avec nous alors
je vois beaucoup de commentaires sur sur
le fait que les images se ressemble un
petit peu dans les médias lors il faut
savoir que le cortège est assez petit on
est à senna c1 depuis tout à l'heure par
les forces de l'ordre et qu'on se
retrouve bien très proches les uns des
autres en ce qui concerne les médias
notamment j'ai pu voir dans les
commentaires des mentions à bfm ou allah
ou alerter
bah oui parce qu'en fait on n'est
vraiment pas loin ensemble
ici au sein de cette tête de cortège je
vais enlever document sera beaucoup
mieux et donc voilà en fait qui s'il est
l'image se ressemblent c'est parce qu'on
est on n'a pas grand chose à faire c'est
un peu compliqué aujourd'hui
peut voir des confrères vous le voyez
juste juste et dernièrement quelques
quelques mètres seulement facile de
pouvoir vous les voulez faire voir
dedans c'est un peu compliqué mais voilà
il ya des confrères qui sont là vous
voyez la caméra qui déborde ici qui sont
juste répéter et qui donc attendre avec
vous c'est un peu difficile aujourd'hui
cette manifestation déjà puisque c'est
chaud ensuite parce qu'il faut porter
les rangs ce qui est ça je peux vous
dire que à couvrir c'est assez compliqué
c'est la première fois que je vois ce
que pour autant que le reste est du
matériel
et voilà en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne l'origine des images
[Musique]
enfin d'autres commentaires ou dinho sur
youtube on dit que vous avez du mal à
comprendre le but de tout ça et bien
cette manifestation fait simplement et
là pour aussi montré que pour endiguer
du jeu différent c'est l'objectif en
tout cas c'est ce qu'a dit jérôme
rodriguez et quelques mètres de moi tout
à l'heure il ya à peu près une heure
avant le lancement soleil
l'idée c'était mon truc du moment des
gilet jaune est toujours là qu'il est
bel et bien présent on peut le voir dans
beaucoup de rassemblement qui ne coûte
pas forcément dédié au gilet jaune en a
plein d'argent de la marche d'un matelot
et là l'objectif c'était de règlement
n'est pas moi qui l'ait toujours raison
et de montrer aussi que bien vis-à-vis
de ce mouvement les colères qui
représente sont toujours présentes avec
vous le savez bien
ces revendications dont la revendication
souvent de manière d'une reconstitution
d'un rique aussi d'un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et bien ces
revendications qui sont bel et bien le
gâteau
ici en france depuis deux ans bien sont
toujours là en tout cas pour cette
partie de la population
[Musique]
j'ai aussi beaucoup de commentaires au
sein et les mesures sanitaires ici alors
comment certains moments culturels qu'on
peut avoir lieu et qui ont pu choquer
dans les médias qu'on a pu voir
notamment un grand rassemblement musical
aniche avec les dizaines de milliers de
personnes
en tout cas des milliers bien ici aussi
on peut voir que les règles sanitaires
sont pas forcément appliqué la
distanciation bien évidemment mais c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué de faire une
manifestation avec avec les avec les
contraintes pour les crises sanitaires
et bien il est geste maria
à
merci à vous en tout cas salissures
twitch pour votre votre message on va
écouter merci de retrouver saicourt mais
on a plaisir à vous retrouver n'hésitez
pas à nous retrouver quotidien pour de
l'actus sur la page principale du figaro
sur youtube sur pourquoi facebook
également sur fritsch essayer en tout
cas de vous montrer tous les tous les
mouvements sociaux qui peuvent avoir
lieu au plus près sans fil et pouvoir
vous donner aussi des témoignages de ce
qu'on peut observer
[Musique]
merci il a donc beau des trucs merci
beaucoup de votre message également je
vous salue tous en tout cas n'hésitez
pas à commenter à réagir et si vous avez
des questions à m'adresser
j'y répondrai avec mon désir vous
l'entendez en tout cas la prostration de
vocaux de manifestants qui appellent à
avancer faut dire qu'ils sont assez
depuis depuis longtemps le mouvement a
commencé à partir d'environ idier il y
avait déjà des rassemblements à 10
heures mais les succès
[Applaudissements]
je vais
il faut répondre et starbucks sur
youtube
avenue de villiers en direction d'un
porte de champerret sur paris
[Musique]
parent
la batterie
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
m
[Musique]
refus de prestations ici excusez moi on
resterait que l'oxygène ici beaucoup de
frustration vous l'avez vu ici avec
cette tentative un petit peu de pousser
les boucliers pour demander à avancer au
taux de prestation qui lui a valu
d'abord comment l'as tu sais pas du tout
ce que l'on peut appeler des ter avenue
des ternes ce solitaire n'est pas couché
pagnol voilà vous le savez comme je le
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a rien
d'autre un autre qui est qui et pas loin
et c'est dur à cuire un petit peu donc
en alerte et coup de spray au poivre
on résiste pour pas les derniers à
passer un très agréable
à nouveau
maintenant beaucoup
[Musique]
ans
c'est pas pareil
alors excusez moi petit à petit
intervention
musique il
non
ouais alors non merci en tout cas pour
vos commentaires sont
avec je suis un peu déçu par une amie
que je dis pas ce que j'aurais aimé
faire comme d'habitude
d'habitude on va vraiment en contact les
manifestants ont des interviews on
essaye de vous faire vivre de
l'intérieur les manifestations et des
mobilisations
là c'est plus compliqué parce que vous
l'avez vu ça peut partir d'un instant à
l'autre et j'aime pas trop lancer des
interviews dans ce contexte ce que ça
peut très vite devenir dangereux nous
v'la vous l'avez vu cette frustration
qui est assez forte des manifestants qui
sont pas parqués depuis depuis depuis
midi qui ont à revendre l'occasion
d'avancer et qui aimeraient pouvoir
avancer et ne pas rester sur place
on a donc beaucoup de
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions assez
assez vive à ce qui vient de se passer
vous l'avez vue sur ces images et bien
les manifestants ont essayé de pousser
un petit peu et ont repris quelques
coups de matraque et surtout plus 15 du
gaz histoire pour ça que vous avez
attendu autour de moi les gens étaient
ravis à tous et même le mouillé qu'est
ce qui vous arrive et qu'elle ne
bouchait
vous l'avez vu dans quel se manifestant
qui crachent terrain allemand du sang ce
sont des images assez impressionnante on
n'avait jamais vu ça alors je ne sais
pas s'ils commencent à ses pairs
mais en tout cas c'est assez
impressionnant
c'est aussi la réalité des mouvements
sociaux
[Musique]
avec bien ici vous pouvez le voir les
manifestants qui lève les mains en signe
de paix face au règne pour policiers
pour éviter qu'il y ait une réponse
[Musique]
mais
non
[Musique]
marveaux de voyages snav montrer ces
images vous voyez ce et reporter de la
rai et cette année
on n'en font leur boulot sans être
alors on avait quelques questions sur le
pour le rapport entre les manifestants
et les journalistes qui a évolué tout à
fait pacifique
et c'est avant tout parce que j'ai vu il
y avait aussi plusieurs rixes avec des
journées se souvient notamment par
exemple la porter j'ai pas de france
télévisions qui avait été roué de coups
mais c'est peut-être cette ambiance la
personne
au contraire les relations avec les
journalistes sont plutôt faciles et on
sent que les
si d'habitude de la presse après sa
position et sa présence au sein d
alors qu'il ya de nouveau de nouveau une
charge
les manifestants sur les forces de
l'ordre
[Musique]
à
au nahd lacrymogène on va s'occuper
excusez moi je vais baisser la caméra de
ton équipe et je vous retrouve dans
quelques secondes
[Musique]
avec des droites
si tu veux
[Musique]
à
c'est un drame
[Musique]
non
obama
m
[Musique]
alors
c'est tout
notre convoi
[Musique]
or beaucoup
fermeture
j'espère que ces bêtes de fonctionnaires
pour septembre
on est cinq ans dames
de tout ce qui se fait chez les
personnes qui ont été mutilés
mais je peux vous répondre directement
c'est toujours été mon nouveau jouet
révéler ce qui est de m mais qui veulent
se faire à un rythme je vous le savez
certainement ça devient de plus en plus
d'y élever mètres de chez les jeunes et
c'est identifier
mais porter deux présentes constituent
un danger
camuzat était prêt à nous ni celle des
manifestants c'était l'époque l'abbé
gellée jeunes qui veulent manifester et
hirèche et entre déchirés mais qui sait
le jeu le jeune et je ne paierai pas
chez un célèbre le personnel qui m était
d'attirer des médecins bûche un peu plus
et vous quels souvenirs que vous avez
vous ai pas fait tout simplement de
participer les accès
mais porter ce prêt serait visée d'une
autre façon le cru s'est choisi un blanc
le bébé est ce que tous les trois sur le
doute est sous pression
celle ci vous sinon on se fait ici
puisque partager de nouvelles terres
mais malheureusement je suis un peu déçu
parce que mes cheveux on peut le faire
le temps de faire ce bilan
on devrait connaître un peu mieux mais
ne pourra leur résister la tête de
chelsea serait possible
je serai bientôt la semaine prochaine si
je sais je sais
côté un petit pépin s'est fait comme ça
et je mets ce que juste en dessous et la
cyber sécurité
ces boulettes sur un portable
bakou
[Applaudissements]
il
je sais un mixer la chair
[Applaudissements]
vite et détient je te préviens si c'est
que dix pays donateurs de presse qui est
anti le spa cible est qui qui permet
d'être visible même de loin c'est
important parce que me confèrent ses
chais bouteilles d'eau si bien qu'elle
ait réduit avec chen a fait beaucoup de
manifestations
et bien sûr il a été pris un petit peu
partie par le ps de l'aisne est elle est
faible chez les jeunes le prime a été
tout à fait douce mais on a eu plusieurs
problèmes avec les options y compris
quelques coups fusent et les prunes mais
aussi après la détient je n'ai donc
limités à cette seule est dans la
plupart du temps ce sont deux éléments
semblent bel et bien on va te presse et
on essaie de marquer c'est chez le 4e
but est peut être bien visibles nations
ce qui est généré le plus visible c'est
tous ces périls étonnant puisque dès que
l'effet de la bnrm simuler le fait pour
le journaliste me tester j'ai un maximum
mais on va peut-être est-ce enfin ça
c'est ce que fait un analyste c'est
important
bon tout est sur cette question bellucci
je compte demander le respect des
libertés jld et bien supporter je
l'espère minutes tout simplement à peine
de chez pc en tout cas ici qui déplaît
il a peiné c'est un plaisir et baisse
vers l'été 2010 mais rien sur ses skis
tc 6 et je puisse peser 12
le prix mais pas prétentieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a prêté deux lycées verser les
primes se quitter je vais très vite chez
free on espère que le pouce de terrain
toutes les années cela n'empêche pas
super youtube n'hésitez pas à naître